tu
ils étaient près de 250 milles à défiler
en plein centre de berlin mais aussi l
think i ou à bruxelles en marge du
sommet européen
tout d'un coup on perd tout ce qu'on a
quand qui démocratiquement pendant des
dizaines et des dizaines d'années
objectif contrer le type le traité de
libre échange entre les états unis et
l'union européenne
un combat largement relayée par les
politiques ils font pas un marché unique
pour élever les normes environnementales
ou sociales
tout va être alignée par le bas
libéralisation des marchés publics
tribunaux arbitraux convergence
réglementaire
la commission européenne assure que la
conclusion d'un tel traité serait
bénéfique pour union en termes de
croissance et d'emploi et elle le fait
savoir
les consommateurs européens et gagneront
sur les prix et sur le choix
la commissaire au commerce cécilia
maelström le garantis les négociations
prennent en compte les inquiétudes des
citoyens notamment sur la question
sensible des tribunaux arbitraux à
travers le débat il est clair qu'il ya
eu et qu'il y a encore un manque de
confiance de la part du public vis-à-vis
de l'équité et de l'impartialité du
mécanisme de règlement des différends
entre investisseurs et alors que le 11e
tour de négociations vient de s'ouvrir
la commission n'est pas près d'avoir
convaincu la population